he is ageless at age 37 and still
getting it done as tight an for the
Saints a tough game last night
running back Mark Ingram says he's so
ripped he looks like the Under Armour
mannequin here from the Afro mentioned
players coalition is in New Orleans
Saints Ben Watson hey van great to see
how you doing why you don't look all
right I'm not bad the Under Armour
mannequin and that that ain't bad I
think I saw that I'm like gosh that
that's got to make you feel good even if
you had a tough tough game last night
you heard the angle Ben your your
thoughts on where things are now given
the hundred million dollars almost the
NFL has given over to various groups
including this players coalition how do
you feel well well I think the bigger
thing that we're missing in this whole
conversation is the fact that what Colin
did by kneeling was one tick along the
long spectrum of players and Americans
who are concerned about what's going on
in this country people everyday people
fathers brothers sisters are all
concerned when they see things that
happen on television maybe they
experience something themself and so
what Colin did obviously brought a lot
of attention but this is one thing along
a long spectrum and specifically when
you talk about the coalition look
tomorrow we're actually having a
listener learn tour in New Orleans
learning about the criminal justice
system educating ourselves hearing from
grassroots organizations who are
involved in this going to bail hearings
hearing from people who are now able to
vote because of a law that was recently
passed here in the state of Louisiana so
so players are engaged players want to
learn players want to advocate and I
heard Burgess say something before about
what guys are not doing let me tell you
something I'm a father of five I live
here in New Orleans I'm in a room I lock
them with 53 other guys from various
places around the country and we do go
into our communities we do encourage
young people we do tell them that they
can do whatever they want to do in my
house I tell my kids that they can
become whatever they want to be but I'm
also real with them I'm also real with
them Lord telling them that they're all
certain are certain challenges that
they're going to face because of the
color of their skin
well this is what Eric Reid said you
know who obviously was supporting Colin
Kaepernick early on he's at
free-agent I guess he hasn't been signed
with anyone yet which is tragic because
he's really good player but why he left
the players coalition this is from
November 2017 he said when we agreed to
be a part of the players coalition we
were under the impression that it would
be our organization we were under the
impression that we would all have equal
say but we've come to find out that it's
actually malcolm and anne Kwan's
organization nobody else really has a
stake in the organization
Malcolm actually wants us to he calls it
invest I call a donate to the company to
pay salaries for his staff but again we
would have no equity what's your
reaction to his ongoing complaint about
what happened with this players
coalition we're a huge amount of money
is going into concerns about where that
money is actually ending up where who's
who's getting what and what audit is
being done and all that well well well
the the there is auditing it is an
official 501 you know all that stuff is
right the NFL wouldn't be giving money
if he they didn't know how to trace it
and know where it's going so all that
stuff is taken care of as far as as Eric
um you know he is I'm glad you mentioned
that he's a great player because he is a
great player and he's one that should be
in this league and him and Malcolm have
have dealt with their differences and
this is September this isn't months ago
so I'm not going to comment on where
they all right now because I believe
that they they're definitely in a better
place but but again where we are now is
different you know players are poised to
make a difference and that's exactly
what we're going to do did you need the
donation from the NFL to be involved in
your communities because I know a lot of
you guys do a lot already you did it
before Colin Kaepernick and you're doing
it after Colin Kaepernick so again it
looks like from the outside and even
some of the more left-wing critics of
you guys and their people on the left to
really think you guys were just bought
off like this guy Steven Crockett at the
root I guess I'll put up the full screen
band so you can hear what I say says
Malcolm Jenkins sounds like a man who
turned his back on Harriet Tubman to do
the good work of making sure he can
affect change from inside the plantation
please stop calling Malcolm Jenkins the
face of Colin Kaepernick's movement that
would be like saying ben Carson is doing
the work that Malcolm X started well
that's a nasty comment about ben Carson
but you get the point that that that you
guys
were too quick to take the money instead
of continuing the protest and standing
against what the NFL owners are really
all about you're getting hit by both
sides the left and the right I guess
yeah well honestly Laura I can
understand how from the outside it may
look that way but when you're on the
inside and you understand again that
generations of players coming to this
point and moving forward are going to be
concerned about the issues that all
Americans should be concerned about you
understand that the money being donated
was simply us in the NFL coming together
and negotiating that and then being
willing to to support some of our causes
I think I think that we can learn a
lesson from what has happened here
because on the outside again and when
you watch the news and when you hear the
tribalism that's going on there's a lot
of back-and-forth but there's no
communication and what we've done
between players and the league is that
come together communicate they
understand the things we're concerned
they're learning about it and because
they want to support our initiatives but
then why not work with President Trump I
mean he's doing criminal justice reform
prison reform he's reached out to you
guys given that Olive Branch saying you
guys have ideas bring him to my
committee and we'll consider them I'll
let you have the last word briefly this
is the president United States he has
ample resources he has gone through
thousands and thousands of people who
need pardons we wrote an op-ed actually
talking about we want systemic change
not just a part in here there although
that may be great for someone that that
happens we want needs to be a place
don't even have these again it happens
so it's broader than that but I get what
we do we do law I get it but what many
President on his willingness but okay so
what I'm saying is they are doing prison
reform now and he has expressed as I
played in the angle a desire perhaps and
which kind of ticks off a lot of
conservatives but to do a broader
criminal justice reform he's bringing in
all these people including Van Jones
who's also getting money from the from
the NFL so why not you know forget the
politics for a moment say we could
actually get something done with this
president even with all of our
differences on other issues or his tweet
tweets or whatever you know I'm saying
like gets come and talk to him I think
you'd actually you'd actually find
someone who would actually want to work
with you on a lot of things that's my my
sense well final thoughts
well after I get off this interview
please
for me the president's number so that I
can contact him directly so we can come
work as players we were open to any
invitation from the president United
States obviously and we would go work
with him but but for me I'll say this
one thing for me this issue of Justice
is important because in the Book of
Micah it says to justly and to walk
humbly with your God and so I love shoes
but thank you so much Ben watts